digamos que ya es 5 - 3x sobre x al
cuadrado 3x y nosotros queremos
encontrar la derivada de y con respecto
a x tal vez en estos momentos estás
pensando que ya es una expresión
racional que ya es el cociente de dos
expresiones distintas incluso lo
podríamos ver como dos funciones
distintas podríamos decir que esto es la
función de x lo que podríamos decir que
esto es igual
de x / vdx si vemos a esta función de
acá como ve de x así es que si tenemos
una función que se puede escribir como
el cociente de otras dos funciones
entonces podemos utilizar la regla del
cociente y recuerda siempre que se te
olvide la regla del cociente la puedes
derivar de la regla del producto y ya
tenemos muchos vídeos de la regla del
producto porque es más fácil de recordar
pero a ver si tenemos esta función ya y
queremos encontrar la derivada de jake
con respecto a x si tenemos aquí de de x
lo único que tengo que hacer aquí es
volver a escribir la regla del producto
esto va a ser igual a la derivada de la
función que se encuentra en el numerador
de de x de
de x
por la función que se encuentra en el
denominador por b de x menos la función
que se encuentra en el numerador y de x
la derivada de la función que se
encuentra en el denominador o sea de de
x de b de x aquí tenemos que dividir
todo entre la función que está en el
denominador al cuadrado
o sea b de equis elevada al cuadrado
bueno tal vez se ve un poquito
complicado pero no lo es porque sólo
tenemos que pensar en cuál es la
derivada de v x cuál es la derivada de
vd x sustituir esas derivadas y ya
tenemos esta expresión entonces vamos
paso por paso primero vamos a encontrar
la derivada de v x vamos a ponerla por
acá la derivada con respecto de x de q
x es igual a haber por aquí tenemos q de
x la derivada de 50 pero la derivada de
menos 3x con respecto a x es menos 3 si
alguna parte de este cálculo te parece
poco familiar o extraño te recomiendo
que repases las propiedades de las
derivadas y la regla de las potencias
bueno y ahora pensemos cuál es la
derivada con respecto de x de la función
de de x la derivada de x al cuadrado
pues simplemente tomamos el exponente lo
ponemos al principio y multiplicamos por
x a la 2 - 1 pero dos menos uno es uno y
esto es igual a dos por equis y luego la
derivada de 3x es simplemente 3 así es
que la derivada de vd x es 12 x + 3 y
ahora si ya tenemos todo lo que
necesitamos sustituir por acá
la derivada de x con respecto de x esto
lo tenemos aquí es menos 3 luego estamos
multiplicando por b de x vdx lo tenemos
aquí es x al cuadrado más 3x y luego de
x sabemos que es 5 menos 3 x es 5 menos
3 x y luego la derivada de vd x con
respecto a x la tenemos por acá es 2x
más 32 x más 3 y finalmente bb x tenemos
por acá que es x al cuadrado más 3 x
esta expresión la tenemos que elevar al
cuadrado entonces que tenemos por aquí
bueno pues va a estar un poquito
enredoso pero todo esto es igual
primero nos vamos a enfocar en este
pedazo tenemos que distribuir al menos
tres en esta expresión así es que
tenemos menos 3 por x al cuadrado menos
3 x al cuadrado menos 9 x y luego a esto
le vamos a restar restar la
multiplicación de estas dos expresiones
así es que calculemos esa multiplicación
tenemos un 5 por 2 x eso es 10 x + 5 x 3
eso es 15 y luego tenemos un menos 3 x x
2 x eso es menos 6 x al cuadrado y luego
menos 3 x por 3 menos 9 x pero a ver
podemos simplificar esta expresión más
si podemos aquí tenemos 10 x menos 9 x
10 x 9 x es simplemente x
y luego en el denominador tenemos esta
expresión que podemos simplemente
dejarla así o si quisiéramos podríamos
expandirla pero yo simplemente la voy a
dejar así esto es x al cuadrado más 3x y
todo eso al cuadrado bueno pero todavía
no hemos terminado aquí lo podemos
simplificar más esto es igual a menos 3
x al cuadrado menos 3 x al cuadrado
menos 9 x y luego tenemos este signo
negativo entonces tenemos menos x menos
x y luego menos 15 y finalmente menos
menos 6 x al cuadrado así es que aquí
nos queda más
6x al cuadrado y esto se divide entre x
al cuadrado más 3x al cuadrado pero
simplificamos el numerador aquí tenemos
menos 3x al cuadrado más 6x al cuadrado
estos términos juntos son 3x al cuadrado
luego tenemos menos 9 x y también
tenemos menos x y estos dos términos
juntos son menos 10x y luego tenemos
menos 15 y listo ahora si ya terminamos
esto es igual a 3 x al cuadrado menos 10
x menos 15 entre x al cuadrado más 3 x
cuadrado